una contraofensiva relámpago que está
cambiando el rumbo de la guerra y
amplias sonrisas en estos soldados
ucranianos que son aclamados como héroes
en las ciudades y pueblos liberados
sentimos la misma emoción cuando
liberamos la región de schumi cuando te
encuentras con residentes felices que te
dicen por fin estás aquí es muy emotivo
tras los rápidos avances ucranianos la
retirada rusa queda al descubierto desde
tanques con la letra zeta a los equipos
de comunicación y lo más importante las
reservas de munición
vamos a enviar toda esta munición a los
rusos como un pequeño regalo nos hace
felices poder hacerlo en las primeras
horas en la ciudad de acción el humo
sigue saliendo de los edificios signos
de varios días de intensos combates la
ciudad había servido como base
estratégica de reabastecimiento para el
ejército ruso pero hoy la bandera azul y
amarilla vuelve a ondear entre las
ruinas
es decir que estoy feliz es un eufemismo
ni siquiera tengo palabras para expresar
lo
teníamos lágrimas en los ojos llevamos
seis meses esperando a nuestros soldados
no pensábamos que llegarían tan rápido y
estamos muy contentos
moscú había expresado su retirada como
una reagrupación planeada de antemano
pero las emisiones de la televisión
estatal durante el fin de semana
cambiaron el tono admitiendo que había
abandonado su principal bastión en el
noreste a pesar del revés el ejército
ruso dijo que bombardeo zonas retomadas
por ucrania no lejos de jarque